[Musik]
vielleicht hast du es ja gar nicht
bemerkt aber in diesem jahr fanden die
olympischen spiele statt ja wir sprechen
über das jahr 2021 das wichtigste
sportereignis der welt wurde in einer
der faszinierendsten städte der welt
ausgetragen tokio der hauptstadt der
mangas es nur reis und natürlich das
sushi doch all das reichte wohl nicht
aus und deine aufmerksamkeit zu erregen
und das sage nicht nur ich das sagen
ganz klar die daten denn wie es hieß
einschaltquoten für tokio 2020 sind die
niedrigsten seit den olympischen spielen
1988 der rückgang der zuschauerzahlen
ist katastrophal wir sprechen hier von
25 bis 30 prozent weniger zuschauern
weltweit aber dieser absturz ist weitaus
dramatischer als einem diese nackten
zahlen vermitteln können
denn noch vor ein paar jahren waren die
olympischen spiele der feuchte traum
eines jeden staatsoberhauptes schien
eine unumstößliche wahrheit zu sein dass
die ausrichtung der olympische spiele
das beste was einem land passieren
konnte und ist auf positive weise ins
zentrum der globalen
aufmerksamkeitsökonomie zu bringen die
olympischen spiele 1992 in barcelona zum
beispiel haben gezeigt dass spanien ein
modernes und demokratisches land ist
gegen 2008 zeigte die macht des neuen
china tokio 2020 beziehungsweise 21 hat
japan jedoch nichts als schande gebracht
und nein es ist nicht nur das corona
virus das den spielen einen strich durch
die rechnung gemacht hat es ist vielmehr
so dass wir es ganz einfach mit einem
mega viel in jeder hinsicht zu tun haben
schoss der an box vorstudie olympische
spiele in tokio sind die teuersten
sommerspiele mir von personalpolitik
haben bereits vor zwei jahren
vorausgesagt dass tokio 2020 ein flop
werden würde damals dachten wir noch
dass tokio durch olympia wenigstens ein
paar zusätzliche touristen bekommen
würde aber wegen der korona virus
pantani musste japan die tore des landes
schließen es gab also kein plus an
touristen denn es kamen genau gesagt
überhaupt keine 0 die frage ist also wie
schlimm ist diese olympische katastrophe
für japan werden wir politische
konsequenzen sehen und was uns alle am
meisten betrifft stehen wir vor dem ende
der olympischen spiele so wie wir sie
kennen heute werden wir hier auch
visuell politik all diese fragen
beantworten aber zuerst müssen wir dafür
einen schnellen blick in die geschichte
moschino olympico die phantom olympiade
tokio und olympische spiele das ist eine
hassliebe wir sprechen hier von einem
großen erfolg und zu vielen
enttäuschungen im laufe der geschichte
hat sich tokio fünf mal um die
olympischen spiele beworben das erste
mal im jahr 1940 die japanischen
machthaber wollten die größe ihres
reiches zeigen zu ähnlichen hitler in
berlin vier jahre zuvor das problem
waren nur das 1940 war es der zweite
weltkrieg ausgebrochen war deshalb
musste ja erstmal auf die ausrichtung
der olympischen spiele hat sich im
kollektiven gedächtnis japan sind die
spiele von deshalb 40 jedoch als labor
hoshino iq die phantom olympiade in
erinnerung geblieben zwei jahrzehnte
später versuchte tokio ein comeback um
sich olympia 960 zu sichern aber es
warte bewerbung roms nicht gewachsen
doch mal sagte sich alle guten dinge
sind drei und beim dritten mal hatten
die japaner endlich glück
[Musik]
tokio wurden 164 gastgeber der
olympischen spiele japan nutzte die
gelegenheit um der welt zu zeigen dass
es eine aufstrebende kapitalistische
demokratie geworden war die japanische
hauptstadt lima 46 in schutt und asche
gelegt worden war entwickelte sich zu
einer modernen metropole oder straßen
und hightech infrastruktur wie der
berühmte hochgeschwindigkeitszug wurden
gebaut
es waren die ersten olympischen spiele
die über satellit übertragen wurden ein
technologisches wunderwerk major p und
weil dieses spiel ein solcher erfolg
waren wollten die japaner diese
erfahrung und unbedingt wiederholen das
problem dabei um das problem ist dass
sich der olympische geist 164 stark
verändert hat
die spieler haben sich in ihrer größe
verdoppelt es gibt doppelt so viele
athleten doppelt so viele länder und
doppelt so viele wettbewerber all das
bedeutet dass die organisation das spiel
heute ein vermögen kostet straßen hotels
olympische dorf war stadien und das
alles wird nur für einen 400
nutzungsdauer errichtet jeden monat an
den die spiele stattfinden und was
passiert danach und was passiert danach
sofort einfach mal die brasilianer in
rio sieht ein jahr nach den olympischen
spielen apokalyptisch aus was ich dir
hier präsentiere ist nichts geringeres
als die traurige realität der heutigen
erscheinungsform der olympischen spiele
ein auswuchs der dekadenz verschwendung
und heuchelei den letzten drei
jahrzehnten hat es keine einzige
olympiade gegeben die profitabel war das
hat aber kaum eine rolle gespielt noch
im jahr 2019 freuten sich laut damaliger
umfragen seit 90 prozent der
japanerinnen und japaner auf die spiele
in tokio 2020 für eine handvoll ian
wollten sie sich diesen spaß auf gar
keinen fall entgehen lassen und glaubt
mir wir reden hier über eine menge hände
folien
[Musik]
das ursprüngliche budget betrug 7 3
milliarden dollar das
organisationskomitee gab jedoch
offiziell zu dass diese zahlen schon vor
der eröffnung auf 12,6 milliarden dollar
gestiegen waren durch die verschiebung
und die präventivmaßnahmen gegen null
senken weitere 2 8 milliarden dollar
hinzu so dass die endgültige offizielle
rechnung 15 4 milliarden dollar betrug
eine nachträgliche prüfung der
japanischen regierung schüssel die
gesamtkosten jedoch auf mehr als 28
milliarden dollar dieses umfasst auch
infrastrukturausgaben die in studien wie
von der universität oxford nicht
berücksichtigt werden wenn man dort der
meinung ist dass investitionen sind die
japan früher oder später sowieso hätte
tätigen müssen nach dieser sichtweise
wäre die spiele in peking zusammen mit
den von russland organisierten
winterspielen in sotschi die teuersten
der geschichte aber wenn wir die kosten
und für die organisation der spiele und
die vorbereitung unter die wochenlangen
sportlichen wettkämpfe betrachten hast
tokio einfach keinen rivalen sie haben
alles gegeben denn diese spiele waren
die große wette von premierminister
shinzo abe eine gelegenheit der welt zu
sagen dass japan nach jahrzehnten der
wirtschaftlichen stagnation und der
katastrophen wieder da ist
[Musik]
es wäre eine große ehre für uns die
spiele 2020 in tokio auszurichten gehen
einer der sichersten städte der welt
jetzt und im jahr 2020 einige machen
sich vielleicht sorgen wegen fukushima
ich kann euch versichern dass die
situation unter kontrolle ist shinzo abe
premierminister von japan 2012 bis 2020
ein weiteres ziel der regierung war es
zu zeigen dass japan in sachen
technologie nicht hinter den usa oder
china zurück geblieben ist jahrzehnte
lang war japan das maß aller dinge wenn
es um computer fernseher und videospiele
ging nun wollte man die olympischen
spiele nutzen um einen neuen
technologischen meilenstein in der
olympischen geschichte zu setzen das
problem war nur dass all das ziel
überhaupt nicht mitbekommen haben
mhk wert 200 stunden olympischer spiele
in tokio
ausstrahlen tatsächlich hat der
japanische öffentlich rechtliche
fernsehsender eine menge geld ausgegeben
um übertragungen anzubieten und glaubt
mir sowas ist keine kleinigkeit
schließlich muss sämtliches equipment
von den kameras wird die bearbeitungs
hard und software wissen wir dass
satelliten bandbreiten auch die neue
auflösung und die damit sprunghaft
gestiegenen
datenübertragungsraten abgestimmt sein
nun ja wie finden japaner haben das
alles technisch natürlich hin bekommen
und dafür keine kosten und mühen
gescheut das problem dabei sie haben in
all ihrem alltag vergessen dass bisher
kaum jemand auf der welt ein fernseher
im wohnzimmer stehen hat von handys ganz
zu schweigen daher haben nur wenige
menschen die qualität der sendungen
überhaupt bemerken können das ganze geld
wurde quasi zum fenster hinaus geworfen
aber warte ein moment denn das ist erst
der anfang dieses epischen fiaskos
[Musik]
game over fürs zugang
shakira ist eine der mutigsten comics
der japanischen geschichte die utax die
sich dieses video ansehen brauchen
sicherlich keine große erklärung von mir
worum es geht aber für alle die ihn
nicht kennen es ist ein korrekter 982
veröffentlicht wurde aber im jahr 2019
spielt in diesem comic steht die stadt
neo tokio kurz vor der austragung der
olympischen spiele die wahrheit ist dass
akira steve typische darstellung des
ereignisses den warenausgang der
realität ziemlich genau getroffen hat 40
jahre bevor es passiert ist die
olympischen spiele werden unter dem
vierten corona die rüstung stand in
tokio ausgetragen es ist klar dass diese
spiele einzigartig waren zum einfachen
sie 2021 statt das erste mal in einem
ungeraden jahr und das alles nur weil
die öffentlichkeit wegen corona nicht
auf den tribünen sitzen durfte der
nachfolger von jean so abe
ministerpräsident jedes zugang war
dennoch entschlossen die spiele um jeden
preis abzuhalten pandemie hin oder her
japan bestand darauf die olympischen
spiele auszurichten obwohl sie genau
wussten dass die einst finanzielles
desaster vor sich haben würden eine
entscheidung die noch schwieriger zu
verstehen ist als das ende von akira das
hier geht an dich mein lieber opa co
mehr noch um die spiele überhaupt
irgendwie organisiert zu bekommen
mussten sie die bizarrsten
einschränkungen einführen und pass auf
denn jetzt wird die geschichte erst
richtig heiß oder eher das gegenteil
davon
alkohol erlaubt aber keine kondome
verteilung im olympischen dorf in tokio
so sieht's aus seit 1988 werden im
olympischen dorf kondome verteilt
irgendwo darüber nach athleten sind
junge menschen mit attraktiven hormon
getränken körper nach klar laufen da die
ganze zeit tat dies ohne ende aber
während der ära des kroner virus gibt es
keine kondome ich meine wäre es nicht
einfacher gewesen die umrisse spiele um
ein weiteres jahr zu verschieben und
aufgepasst das sage nicht ich das war
die meinung einer mehrheit der japaner
40 prozent fordert nun eine weitere
verschiebung weitere 40 prozent wollten
dass tokio die spiele ganz aufgibt
überleg mal während die normalen bürger
japans eine menge dauernde
einschränkungen ertragen mussten wussten
sie dabei zusehen wie 50.000 sportler
aus was 200 verschiedenen ländern ins
land kamen und das alles nur weil ein
paar politiker wieder mal nicht der lage
waren ihr gesicht zu verlieren man nur
man
dabei ist japan mit kuwait 19 recht gut
zurecht gekommen das land hat 126
millionen einwohner und eine sehr alte
bevölkerung aus dem gab es seit beginn
der pandemie nur etwa 17.000 todesfälle
in zusammenhang mit dem corona virus die
japaner nahmen die einschränkungen und
maßnahmen sehr ernst ausgerechnet am 20
august zwölf tage nach der
abschlusszeremonie gab es jedoch fast
26.000 coroner positiv getestete fälle
es war der tag mit der höchsten zahl an
infektionen seit beginn der pandemie
[Musik]
traurig sehen auch die wirtschaftlichen
zahlen aus es wurde erwartet dass die
veranstaltung zwei millionen
arbeitsplätze schaffen und dank
investitionen tourismus und erhöhten
konsum einen positiven effekt von 128
milliarden dollar auf die japanische
wirtschaft haben würde und ja viele von
euch werden denken dass diese prognosen
immer übertrieben sind aber das
tatsächliche ergebnis lag ziemlich nahe
bei null
sie konnten nicht einmal ein einziges
ticket loswerden die großen japanischen
unternehmen haben auch keinen gewinn
gemacht sie haben insgesamt 3,6
milliarden dollar für werbung ausgegeben
aber die öffentlichkeit war so verärgert
dass toyota sogar seine ganze
werbekampagne im zusammenhang mit den
spielen zurückzog obwohl der
automobilgigant ein hauptsponsor des ioc
ist
das große vermächtnis von tokio 2020
sind daher rekord mäßig hohe berge von
rechnungen 28 milliarden dollar von
denen 15,4 milliarden nur die kosten für
die organisation der einmonatigen spiele
sind bis auf 67 milliarden dollar werden
all diese kosten vom japanischen
steuerzahler getragen wir reden hier von
einer summe die für den bau von 300
krankenhäusern ausgereicht hätte oder
für steuersenkungen welche die
wirtschaft sich ja mehr angekurbelt
hätten als ein turm wettbewerb die
niemand sehen wollte und wenn du dir
vorstellen kannst brachte minister sogar
deswegen auch ganz neue rekorde nämlich
in seine unbeliebtheit die spiele
besiegelte sein schicksal
game over für den regierungschef auf
bildschirm wird er so schnell nicht
wieder auftauchen wieder in aiken noch
in popelige vga auflösung
joschi jedes sogar tritt als japans
premierminister zurück und darf sogar
nicht mehr im amt ist um die suppe
auszulöffeln muss sich sein nachfolger
in der vor ende november den
parlamentswahl stellen mal sehen welcher
arme tropf der japaner das sagen müssen
dass nun rekord mäßige steuererhöhungen
auf sie zukommen denn die schulden des
japanischen staates haben bereits derart
monströse ausmaße erreicht dass godzilla
neben ihnen wie süße kleine hexe
aussieht und gut japan hat mit olympia
ganz schön abgelöst das dürfte uns jetzt
die nicht klar seien viele werden sich
jedoch fragen ob diese tower spiele denn
eigentlich auch auswirkungen auf den
rest der welt hatten nun ja die hatten
sie und das nicht zu knapp tokio 2020
wird eine zeitenwende markieren das ende
einer langen ära nichts wird mehr so
sein wie zuvor setzt euch also jetzt mal
lieber hin
die olympische flamme erlischt
die olympischen spiele sind ein bisschen
wie hochzeiten eine menge geld wird
verschwendet für einen kurzen moment des
genusses der dann sehr schnell vergeht
viel schneller als die ernüchterung und
der große kater danach dort dann ist es
der traum eines jeden landes sie zu
veranstalten als sich zum beispiel
madrid um die ausrichtung der
olympischen spiele beworben hat musste
man dort vorsichtig damit sein wenn man
dagegen war schnell wurde man als
aussätzige abgestempelt als mieser
querulant und verräter sie haben und am
ende verlor madrid gegen tokio aber die
spanier haben tolle erinnerungen an ihre
kandidatur in ihrem tadellosen englisch
versuchte die damalige bürgermeisterin
madrid das internationale olympische
komitee zu überzeugen schau mal was für
eine tolle arbeit geleistet hat
[Musik]
und ich versichere dir dass niemand das
leben so feierte die spanier es gibt
nichts besseres als eine entspannte
tasse café con leche auf der plaza mayor
oder ein ruhiges romantisches abendessen
ml madrid delos austria
die die von euch fragen sich vielleicht
was ich gegen die olympischen spiele
habe nun eine ganze menge mal abgesehen
von der toxischen kommerzialisierung und
verantwortungslosen geldverschwendung
sind die wurzel allen übels die durch
und durch korrupten ioc-mitglieder das
problem dabei war jahrzehntelang das
ihren jede stadt und jeder staat welcher
die spiele abhalten wollte das tief an
jene stellen kriechen musste die noch
nie einen sonnenstrahl erblickt haben
überzeugungsarbeit heißt das dann das
internationale olympische komitee ist
eine jener organisationen welche überall
die beste behandlung der welt erhält
jedes mal wenn sie eine kandidatenstadt
besuchen wird der luxus ausgerollt und
wie sich schon bei mehreren
gelegenheiten herausgestellt hat müssen
die mitglieder des ioc ihre stellung
äußerst gewinnbringend zu nutzen
ende der 1990 er jahre schluss dass eu
zehn ehrenmitglieder wegen korruption
aus sie waren bestochen worden um die
olympischen spiele 2002 nach salt lake
city zu holen aber das war beileibe kein
einzelfall die hauptstadt von utah hatte
damals diese strategischen gilt nachdem
sie nur 98 gegen nagano verloren hatte
die japanischen konkurrenten hatten
computer verschenkt während die mormonen
statt nur läppische süßigkeiten und öle
cowboyhüte verteilt hatte es wurde auch
oft geweckt dass mehrere eu sie nicht
wieder melbourne für seine bewerbung
1990 um neue autos gebeten hatten und um
die begleichung ihrer üppigen spesen in
den westen freudenhäuser der
australischen stadt melbourne lehnte ab
und die spiele wurden in atlanta
ausgetragen
[Musik]
wie schon sagte ioc mitglieder wissen
ihre stellungen mit gewinn zu nutzen es
ist klar dass die athleten im
olympischen dorf ein gewisses
verständnis für all diese verhältnisse
haben aber es scheint dass die mit iris
olympischen komitees noch etwas
überzeugungsarbeit leisten müssen und
zwar mit einem lokalen delegierten damit
ja keine zweifel daran bestehen wo die
spiele stattfinden sollen das problem
ist dass sich die menschen bereits daran
gewöhnt haben dass olympia ein
wirtschaftliches risiko darstellt die
misserfolge von rio oder tokio sind
berüchtigt und die zuschauerzahlen an
den fernsehern senken weiter und deshalb
gibt es immer weniger interesse an der
ausrichtung des olympischen mega events
für die verwöhnten ioc mitglieder sind
nachrichten wie diese deswegen ein böses
erwachen
homburg stimmt beim referendum über die
olympischen spiele 2000 24 mit nein ab
olympia in rom 2024 bürgermeister rajhi
sagt nein dass japan die natur ist
unverantwortlich das undenkbare war
plötzlich eingetreten und versenkt hatte
das ioc plötzlich nur noch zwei
bewerbungen für die spiele 2024
vorliegen faust paris und aus los
angeles und damit ihnen diese zwei
tasten fälle nicht auch noch
davonschwimmen wurden die spiele ganz
schnell ohne viel aufhebens vergeben
2024 nach paris und 2028 nach los
angeles es ist also klar dass sich in
der olympischen welt etwas ändert vorbei
die zeiten als mehrere kandidaten um die
gunst des ioc kämpften diese versuchen
ihre kandidatur praktisch geheim zu
halten und nicht ausgelacht zu werden
jetzt muss das eu zu betteln gehen hey
wie wäre es wenn die spiele in deiner
stadt abgehalten werden kommen schon
wird schon nicht so schlimm werden ohne
das ist die welt bemerkt hätte wurde
sogar bereits ein austragungsort für die
spiele 2000 32 festgelegt es gab zwar
keinen wirklichen konkurrenten aber sie
die nur an was für ein theater sie
gemacht haben um doch für ein minimum an
aufsehen zu sorgen the international
community das internationale olympische
komitee hat die ehre bekannt zu geben
dass die spiele der 35 jahre im jahr
2032 in brisbane australien vergeben
werden
[Musik]
da die viele von euch haben schon mal
von brisbane gehört und wie viele können
es auf einer unbeschrifteten karte
australiens mit dem finger finden macht
ruhig mal den test und schreibt mir hier
in die kommentare ob ihr die stadt
gleich gefunden habt oder nicht würde
mich interessieren ob wir über zehn
prozent trefferquote kommen und wenn ihr
schon kommentieren seit denkt doch auch
gleich über folgende fragen nach glaubt
ihr dass die spiele in tokio als ein
symbol des trosses oder eher als eine
katastrophe in erinnerung bleiben werden
werden uns die olympischen spiele noch
lange erhalten bleiben oder droht die
olympische flamme langsam aber für immer
zu erlöschen und was am wichtigsten ist
würdest du wollen dass deine heimatstadt
die olympischen spiele ausrichtet was
würdest du den usa anbieten damit sie
den zuschlag bekommt oder damit sie ja
wegbleiben ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat falls ja gebt uns mit
einem like teil ist mit euren freunden
und vergesst nicht das abo mit glöckchen
und keines unserer videos mehr zu
verpassen macht gut und bis bald
[Musik]